we got we got more news in the
censorship field oh boy we got the story
from daily mail
instagram censors evolutionary
biologists for posting a chart from
transgender study by prominent science
journal that showed biological men are
stronger than biological women in a
range of olympic sports
evolutionary biologist colin wright had
one of his instagram posts removed for
hate speech and claims he was unable to
appeal his review now for those that
aren't familiar colin's actually been on
this show
and he didn't post any hate speech
he posted science yep so he basically
was disparaging fouchy that explained
wait wait no no no no
i'm sorry instagram is disparaging fauci
because fauci is science oh yeah right
yeah so that's how it works i'm told yes
okay there we go so so instagram hates
science
all right
colin wright tweeted instagram took down
one of my posts for violating the rules
on hate speech what was thing i posted a
figure from fond of beatles and tl
exercises peer-reviewed paper showing
male advantage in certain sports
activity they said avoid losing access
to your account in the future this shows
the chart that the chart was taken from
a study published in medicine and sports
in sports and exercise which tested if
the international olympic committee's
guidelines for transgender athletes
eliminated the performance advantage
male athletes male athletes bodies give
them naturally as we can see there is
absolutely according to the study a male
advantage although i'm not here to talk
necessarily about the study just the
censorship this is this is this is it's
it's crazy okay
they they claim all this the science
agrees the experts agree and then they
just eliminate anybody from social media
who doesn't
so you've got these stories about
vaccine mandates and they're like 97 of
our workforce is vaccinated yeah because
you fired you know the other how many
percentage of them so if you have if you
have 100 people working at your company
and 60 of them get vaccinated and then
you fight and then you fire a handful
and you're like ah see
let's say only 40 were not vaccinated so
you're 60 40. then they fire the 40
people and they say we're 100 vaccinated
that's what's happening they're they're
they they
i don't know what i i just don't even
know are we not allowed to talk about
the contents of that study probably not
but we risk uh getting getting caught
probably not but we are so we are
because this is this is insane look this
is this that is truly insane that you
can't just say that a dude is stronger
than a woman well that's a
generalization not always because some
women are stronger than men so but the
strongest human right
and that's post-modernism oh this is the
point we're talking about in general and
the science shows it there is a very
distinct difference if you're talking
about the extremes the the strongest
humans tend to be men tend to be
are exclusively
it's not a hundred percent every time
every way all the time you might have
some aberrational human that happens to
be a female stronger than the strongest
the point is you might you've not you've
not actually looked at the bell curve
research data on this side i'm just
saying it's not that it can never happen
that's the point
so when you look at uh grip strength for
instance oh here we go we're going to
get videos made about this oh absolutely
people always do response videos
whenever we talk about grip strength why
is that i don't know because they think
it's so it's like a foot pedal there's a
scientific study we went over on the
show and look i'm gonna stress this like
this is not meant to be disrespectful
towards anybody we're just trying to
talk about science here and if we if we
get censored so be it uh the strongest
the the highest um
strength for grip strength among women
is around the average for a man
in the bell curve for uh jumping jumping
height distance jumping height and
distance the highest end of the bell
curve for men has no women anywhere near
it so so when it comes to the strongest
jumping strength or grip strength it is
exclusively like the top percentile is
male now there are some high bell curve
women as well who get very close to the
top but it is
almost entirely i mean
you look at the basket look at the nba
these guys are all what's six seven feet
tall yeah that how many people on the
planet are seven feet tall it's not that
many and that means if there was a there
was a funny uh post i saw that said if
you're over seven feet tall you have a
13 chance of being in the nba
no no it's for real because
even if you're not that good the height
advantage is is sought after for the nba
so this means exclusively people i i
will say it's not exclusive to the nba
buggy bows amazing showing you that
strength and perseverance and talent
really does matter a 42-inch vertical
really helps with that as well right
dude was amazing he was amazing he was
spud webb as well too right yeah yeah so
this is just part of the whole trend of
destroying masculinity and destroying uh
the idea of what a man is and you just
can't have science saying that men are
stronger so we have to eliminate that
and suppress that i think history
logically men were genetically we just
developed men just developed the the
snap strength power because they had to
run and hunt and and no
they ran and hunted because they were
bigger and stronger bro and it's not
like playing basketball
i think it comes from the women's
staying home to protect the child
we're both right yeah yes look
it wasn't like there were two completely
gender neutral humans that one started
hunting and then became bigger or one
was right and and one wasn't bigger
because it was hunting right natural
selection yes selected for those who are
expendable right there's
this really cool there's this really
like uh one last thing on this there's
this this meme that's been going around
in the men's community and fitness
community forever it's like there's an
image of a long-distance runner and an
image of a sprinter and and they people
always use that to be like this is why
long distance running is bad for you and
this is why you should do sprinting
and people people use that as a way to
say that like sprinting is going to make
you strong and powerful and long
distance running is going to make you
weak and frail actually it's just that
those body types are the ones that are
most successful in those individual
sports the people who yeah there it is
the people who use that image to be like
sprinting makes you powerful are the
ones that are would also say that
playing basketball makes you tall it
just does it just is not logic guys i
would slightly disagree with you on your
of course on your previous statement
when you said this is an attack on males
i think that this is an attack on women
because this predominantly affects women
and if you look at what's been happening
socially i think masculine men have been
predominantly widely conquered already
and there still are a lot of outliers
when it comes to women standing up for
the family unit standing up for
femininity standing up for their true
kind of energetic power that they have
within themselves males i think have
that completely wiped out in certain
contexts but
when you look at this policy and this
kind of larger cultural shift i think
this is a directed targeted attack
against femininity and women uh and uh
this is this is the the kind of conflict
that we're seeing unfold right now i
want to add super the grip strength
thing i actually saw another really
interesting study that said grip
strength correlating with uh how much uh
um with with uh uh with your heart with
heart strength and likelihood of like a
heart attack
yeah apparently as as your heart weakens
your grip strength diminishes there's a
there's a vein here i think that goes
directly to your heart on your hand it's
part of why they put rings on that
finger there's like a vein yeah
you know what i have this crazy theory
that all of your veins are connected to
your heart no way dude
that's a crazy theory of making your
intelligence
sorry i want to point out about if you
had an ancient if you had an ancient
tribe of 20 men and 20 women and then
five of the men died you're still going
to be able to produce 50 20 children
we've talked about this uh in fallout uh
the fallout story
uh you got you're familiar with fallout
i imagine right the video game series
there's uh for those those are not
familiar now this is this is good
because people have basically this is a
fiction where humans have written about
these ideas uh fallout post-apocalyptic
wasteland the government builds a bunch
of underground bunkers called vaults one
of the vaults was called vault 69 where
it was i think it was 99 women and one
man
and then there was another vault called
i think was vault 68 where it was 99 men
and one woman that's not going to work
so so at the end of the day there was
one man left they write about this
because uh
you know the idea is if you have 100 men
and 100 women and 99 men die your
civilization is fine i mean it's hurt
it's it's it's your culture your tribe
whatever is hurt but it will survive
because you can have 99 babies in nine
months basically the point of this is
yeah maybe history nine months in a week
men were genetically like more
disposable they built up a little bit
more
exactly like bodies that could handle
like trauma in short term and they would
go and do dangerous things and get
killed off but it was okay because as
long as you still had those 20 women you
could produce 20 children per year five
of the women died you can only produce
15 children per year and that's that's
why you need to have big strong scary
men to defend the women from big strong
scary things this is where gender came
from
it's just men were expendable and uh
it's nature selected for the men who
were more likely to survive and the men
were more likely to survive we're
stronger
world now where we don't have to fight
bears anymore so it's like i think the
consciousness is shifting and people are
starting to think of it differently but
it's still we're still genetically from
what we were we still have to fight
bears uh we had a bear attack here but
we have guns now right um what we have
done is dramatically reduce the threat
to to the need for muscle
and so now what's happening i think is a
natural consequence of this is that
nature is now selecting uh outside of
the parameters of expendability or
strength
now
how does that happen women are the ones
that select
women are the ones that select for
strength and power and perhaps the the
issue was
the reason why these men didn't
procreate was because they were weaker
and they would die when they tried to
fight a wolf or a bear no and the
stronger men survived and had the kids
right now it perhaps women make
selections based on a large variety of
factors which doesn't include pure
strength kill the bear come back to the
village
get all the brides now it's there's no
real bear fight for most people in
cities so it's but psychologically there
is right it's like a bar get drunk have
kids
psychologically though there is still
the need the there is still the need to
be a protector right and i think that
that's that's the more meta element of
this is is protect and provide versus
nurture and care and i don't know that
those elements are gone
right people like women seem to enjoy
this is very big generalization guys
that can fix things now like fix broken
pipes i hear a lot like i want a man
that can go out there with a chainsaw
and cut down a tree but you do need
muscle for that it helps to be really
strong you can carry branches and
things the more the more that we
automate hard labor
the more
the more weaker men will survive to to
but those are weaker weaker in
physicality but you still have to be
stronger mentally and you still have to
protect and provide so it's uh slightly
modified but protect and provide is
still a thing but it's more about
getting money being funny now is a thing
like it's different it's very we're all
doomed protecting
protecting and providing is very
different so you take a look at what's
going with male feminists what does
protect mean they're gonna defend the
woman and all of her political opinions
right and so they become male feminists
and then provide what does that mean
they're going to go work any job where
they can stand i can't really get paid
and those are the biggest creepers and
predators out there according to some
statistics according to some people's
personal opinions but also dating apps
have had a huge effect on a lot of the
kind of social interactions we have
where the top one percent of males bag a
lot of the women and the okay guy and
the average guy are left uh holding the
bag with not many options for themselves
when women get hit up
no matter what kind of scale there are
on the 0 to 10 scale
they get thousands of messages no matter
what so that also has a huge effect on
socially what's happening right now and
overall there's been less marriages less
relationships less people making kids in
the western world and i think those
consequences and those effects
especially when you look at what's
happening in china when they're trying
to prioritize masculine men they're
trying to prioritize families they're
trying to prioritize
uh nationalism and mythology and heroes
this is a completely different approach
and throughout the generations we're
going to see the consequences of those
two different approaches and it's not
going to be good for the united states
this is really interesting because i
wonder you know we talk about the fall
of
of ancient rome and i'm wondering if
something happens with
i guess you'd call it behavioral sync
where if a society becomes well
protected well-fed well-established but
can only grow so fast within the
confines of that does it really does it
lead to behavioral sync thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you